but it's the the logic we
we we live by of trying to to improve
our experience
moment to moment is ironically
uh largely what what degrades
our experience right it's largely what
keeps us from recognizing
that the present moment and and
consciousness as it already is
admits of of real
uh a real discovery of of intrinsic
well-being and intrinsic
tranquility and intrinsic equanimity and
intrinsic compassion and in fact
you know unconditional love and many of
these these very
very positive emotions that you know
people talk about
all of that stuff can be found sort of
before anything changes
in your experience before you are in the
right relationship before you
get the job you're hoping to get before
you you know get better from the
the the illness you're you're hoping to
get better from and
whatever whatever those contingencies
are in your life where you think
if only i can solve this problem uh you
know i'll be i'll be back to zero
um the truth is that that is a kind of
mirage
and most people never discover it
to be so right we just live our lives
seeking happiness
uh and seeking to become happy
yeah and that's the implicit in
everything we're attempting to do and
yet
there's this recognition which is itself
meditation that you actually can't
become happy you can only
be happy right and what what most people
are looking for
are good enough reasons
by virtue of changing their life in the
world
to simply get off the treadmill for some
moments at a time
and recognize that the present moment is
enough
right if i can just you know if if i
just bought you know game stop at the
right moment
you know then i'd i would actually be
able to just relax
and enjoy my life in the present
um and again that is a that is a mirage
even
when it seems to happen for many of us
you know something great happens
and you're just high-fiving everyone
around you you know that lasts for what
15 minutes you know five hours and then
you're faced with the same long
emergency
of just what do i do next and how do i
how do i scratch the itch that is now
back